und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Anne Gellinek guten Abend
was zählt wenn die Welt um uns rauer
wird was zählt wenn unsere Freiheit auf
dem Spiel steht Marke Gesetze aus einem
Werbevideo für die Bundeswehr in dem
junge Soldatinnen und Soldaten in
camouflage Make-up Kampfflugzeuge und
Panzer besteigen das Image der starken
Truppe hat sich seit Beginn des
russischen angriffskriegs eher
verbessert knapp 80% der Befragten
Bürger sehen die Bundeswehr positiv und
halten sie für notwendig nur hingehen
will keiner jedenfalls fast keiner die
Bewerbungen gingen auch in den ersten
fünf Monaten dieses Jahres um 7% zurück
dabei hatte der neue
Verteidigungsminister das Ziel
ausgegeben mehr junge Menschen zum Bund
zu locken Ines Trams und Jan Friedrich
Fischer berichten
schnupper kämpft für die die sich
vorstellen können zur Bundeswehr zu
gehen fünf Tage Truppen Alltag inklusive
minensucht Training heutzutage ist klar
schneller als bisher könnte ein Einsatz
konkret werden viele schreckt das ab die
die hier sind Wissen um die
Verantwortung
vielleicht kommt das wo gerade in der
Ukraine ist zu uns oder so und ich bin
dann eigentlich komplett mittendrin also
ich bin die erste wenn was schlimmes
passiert ich bin die erste die tot ist
ich finde es ja ich finde schon cool
dass ich
helfen kann später und auch ja dann
später im wenn es wenn der Ernstfall
kommt helfen kann mein Land zu
verteidigen
Zeit hat die Bundeswehr 180.000 Soldaten
Ziel sind 203.000 fast unerreichbar
angesichts von demografischen Wandel und
Konkurrenz der Privatwirtschaft das weiß
auch der Verteidigungsminister heute zu
Besuch in einem karrierecenter der
Bundeswehr mehr Frauen mehr Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund fordert er und
mehr Tempo
mir ist wichtig dass wir die Zeitspanne
kurz halten zwischen einer Anfrage bei
der Bundeswehr dem ersten
Beratungsgespräch dem ersten assessment
und einer Einstellung diese Zeitraum wir
müssen kurz sein dazwischen muss betreut
werden dazwischen muss klar gemacht
werden wir haben dich nicht nur einmal
angeguckt wir wollen dich auch ein
Teufelskreis zu wenig Personal bei
wachsenden Anforderungen der NATO es
gilt die Ostflanke zu schützen eine hohe
Belastung für den einzelnen Soldaten die
Abbrecherquote im Herd 30%
versuchte die Bundeswehr bislang sich
als familienfreundlicher Arbeitgeber zu
zeigen als ein Job wie jeder andere
Stellen Werbefilme heute das soldatische
heraus da spricht man die Leute an bei
denen man ohnehin keinen richtigen
Mangel hat also da wo es um klassische
soldatische Arbeit geht bei der
Infanterie bei Fallschirmjägern da sind
gar nicht so große Personal Engpässe die
personalentpässe sind da wo so
technische Spezialisten geht eine
Wiedereinführung von Wehrpflicht und
Grundausbildung würde solche
Spezialisten ebenfalls nicht
hervorbringen zudem fehlt es dafür an
Kreiswehrersatzämtern Kasernen und
Ausbildern
wenn wir jetzt hunderte neue Kasernen
bauen dann investieren wir in Beton und
nicht in Köpfe außerdem würde eine
Wehrpflicht eine Hightech Armee wie der
Bundeswehr überhaupt nicht nutzen weil
wir natürlich Dienstzeiten brauchen von
etwa zwei Jahren bis die jungen Leute
ihre Systeme Waffensysteme und
einsatzsysteme beherrschen was wenn die
Personalnot anhält einige auch die
werbeauftragte denken bereits über eine
Reduzierung von Stärke und Fähigkeiten
nach man kann nicht mit immer weniger
Soldatin und Soldaten immer mehr
Aufträge übernehmen das ist nicht mehr
zu leisten das heißt es braucht eine
schonungslose sehr kritische
Bestandsaufnahme der übernommenen
Aufgaben die Personalmisere gefährdet
die zeitenwände denn die bedeutet nicht
nur Gerät sondern auch Personal
Deutschland fällt wirtschaftlich zurück
ökonomen rechnen mit einem weiteren
Schrumpfen der deutschen Konjunktur im
Laufe dieses Jahres und die
ampelregierung streitet um den richtigen
Weg raus aus der Misere und um ein
Gesetz mit dem schönen färberischen
Namen
wachstumsschancengesetz das Gesetz wird
gerade zwischen FDP Finanzministerium
und grünem Wirtschaftsministerium
abgestimmt heißt es wird gefälscht
welche Maßnahmen nun drin stehen sollen
soll und welche nicht die Grünen wollen
eher mehr Geld ausgeben die FDP die
Schuldenbremse einhalten und die
Wirtschaft meckert jetzt schon dass
alles reiche nicht aus Karl
Hinterleitner berichtet aus Berlin
es ist sommerurlaubszeit und eigentlich
macht da auch die Politik Pause
eigentlich Zeit für neuen Zoff ist aber
auch jetzt die Wirtschaft meldet sich zu
Wort für die Unternehmen in Deutschland
brauche es schnell mehr Entlastung und
weniger Abgaben wir haben hohe Steuern
im internationalen Vergleich sehr hohe
Energiepreise im internationalen
Vergleich das schränkt die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit ein und auch die
Investitionen hierzulande deswegen ist
es wichtig Anreize zu schaffen dass die
Unternehmen hier bleiben und das muss
dann auch bei den Strompreisen gelten
und natürlich auch weiterhin Thema
Steuerpolitik darum geht es in
sogenannten Wachstumschancen gesetzt
plant Finanzminister Lindner rund 50
steuerpolitische Maßnahmen im Zentrum
eine Prämie bei Klimaschutz
Investitionen Entlastung für die
Wirtschaft rund 6,5 Milliarden Euro das
seit zu wenig meinen der
Wirtschaftsminister und die Grünen
aus meiner Sicht braucht es deutlich
mehr Impulse für Investitionen hier in
Deutschland in Europa dass das was
Christian Lindner vorgeschlagen hat ein
kleiner Schritt der aber wirklich
deutlich größer ausfallen müsste das was
er jetzt vorgeschlagen hat reicht noch
nicht um diesen investitionsimpuls den
wir brauchen damit die Wirtschaft sich
zukunftsfähig aufstellen kann auch
wirklich auszufüllen wenn man darüber
hinausgehen möchte was wir als FDP
begrüßen würden dann muss man auf der
anderen Seite aber auch sagen wo die
Gegenfinanzierung ist und das wäre die
Aufgabe von Herrn Harbig nicht einfach
mehr zu fordern sondern zu sagen wo
konkret die Mittel des Staates sind
begrenzt er dann sparen möchte besonders
umstrittene industriestrompreis Minister
habe ich will damit die hohen
energiekostendecke experten sehen das
kritisch ein subventionierter Preis für
die Wirtschaft sei womöglich
kontraproduktiv und bewirke insgesamt
sogar höhere Kosten
erstmal wird es natürlich viele
Diskussionen geben für wen genau das
gelten sollen und dann würden für diese
Industrien würde natürlich die
Stromnachfrage steigen und das hat einen
negativen Effekt auf den Strompreis für
alle anderen die Nachfrage steigt das
Stromangebot ist noch knapp das heißt
der Strompreis für alle anderen würde
steigen die Opposition sieht die Lage
als völlig verfahren an die Regierung
müsste sich einig werden die geplanten
Maßnahmen sein zu zögerlich und nicht
ausgereift also erstens kommt die
Bundesregierung sehr sehr spät jetzt
damit zweitens braucht ein abgestimmtes
breites Konzept das ist auch
Wachstumsimpulse gibt für hier in
Deutschland unserer Industrie und den
Mittelstand und deshalb braucht es auch
ein Krisengipfel im Kanzleramt den wird
es wohl vorher nicht geben der Kanzler
ist im Urlaub der Streit im politischen
Berlin und den richtigen Weg aus der
Krise aber geht weiter
aber wollen wir reden mit Monika
Schnitzer sie ist Professorin für
vergleichende Wirtschaftsforschung an
der Universität München und eine
sogenannte Wirtschaftsweise genauer
gesagt sie ist die Vorsitzende des
Sachverständigenrates der die
Bundesregierung in
wirtschaftspolitischen Fragen bereit
guten Abend nach München guten Abend
Frau Schnitzer guten Abend Deutschland
Wirtschaft wird in diesem Jahr
schrumpfen damit rechnet der
Internationale Währungsfonds während die
Konjunktur anderer großer
Industriestaaten Frankreich
Großbritannien USA weiter wächst was
macht Deutschland falsch
tatsächlich sind die Unterschiede nicht
so groß ja wir werden vermutlich in
diesem Jahr leicht schrumpfen andere
leicht wachsen aber das liegt unter
anderem auch daran dass wir eine andere
Wirtschaftsstruktur haben wir sind ein
Industrieland wir sind momentan stark
von den hohen Energiepreisen betroffen
andere Länder wie zum Beispiel Italien
oder Spanien leben vom Tourismus und die
profitieren momentan davon dass die
Menschen wieder gerne in Urlaub fahren
also der Export der sonst unsere Stärke
ist ist jetzt unsere Schwäche vielleicht
ist es auch typisch deutsch dass
pessimistische Einschätzungen gerade
Konjunktur haben das Wort von
Deutschland als kranke Mann Europas
macht schon die Hunde aber welche
Entwicklung hat Deutschland denn
verschlafen was muss dringend nachgeholt
werden aus ihrer Sicht
nun wir sollten jetzt wirklich dringend
die erneuerbaren Energien ausbauen da
ist ja schon einiges auf den Weg
gebracht worden die lng-terminals gibt
es um kurzfristig für Gaslieferungen zu
sorgen aber wir müssen natürlich dafür
sorgen dass Wind und
Solarenergie schnell aufgebaut werden
dafür müssen wir die Prozesse
beschleunigen wir müssen auch für die
Infrastruktur sorgen damit die die
Energie Lieferung auch dahin kommen wo
man sie braucht und wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass die Verwaltung beschleunigt
wird das haben wir geschafft bei den
lg-terminals als man die genehmigen
lassen musste aber das müssen wir auch
ganz grundsätzlich schaffen wir müssen
die Verwaltung endlich digitalisieren
mehr Prozesse automatisieren das hilft
der Wirtschaft und der Verwaltung die
nämlich dann Personal spart jetzt ist es
aber so dass im Haushalt 2024 die
Ampelkoalition sagt dass sie die Mittel
für Digitalisierung von 300 Millionen
auf 3 Millionen zu Recht kürzen will
hören die nicht auf ihren Rad ja das ist
tatsächlich Sparen am falschen Ende
das haben wir anders empfohlen hier muss
ich sagen hat man wirklich die falsche
Entscheidung getroffen eine Schraube
soll das
wachstumsschancengesetz sein das Prämien
vorsieht für Investitionen in
klimafreundliche Technologien und
steuerliche Abschreibungen habe ich will
dazu noch einen verringerten
industriestrompreis einführen da sagt
jetzt die Wirtschaft das ist zwar die
richtige Richtung aber viel zu wenig der
Finanzminister sagt ist schon viel zu
viel mehr geht nicht wer hat denn jetzt
recht
man muss sich einfach genau überlegen
wofür man Geld ausgibt und man sollte
nicht das Geld ausgeben um einfach die
Struktur so zu erhalten wie wir sie
gerade haben mit viel Energie intensiver
Industrie das wird auf Dauer nicht gut
gehen weil die Energiepreise nicht so
weit wieder runterkommen werden und wenn
ich dauerhaft zu pensionieren kann wenn
wir subventionieren wenn wir
unterstützen dann in den Bereichen wo
wir Zukunftschancen sehen beispielsweise
haben wir das jetzt für die
batterieindustrie oder für
Halbleiterindustrie also Bereiche wo es
wirklich Wachstumschancen gibt und da
muss man eben entsprechend genau die
richtigen Teile der Wirtschaft
unterstützen also ich verstehe sie
richtig Subvention an sich ist nicht
unbedingt ein Wert sondern man muss die
richtigen Dinge subventionieren wie
Klima klimatechnologie aber nicht den
Strompreis finanzieren ja genau also es
geht nicht darum die alte Struktur zu
erhalten sondern in die neuen
Wachstumsbranchen zu investieren und
dazu gehört natürlich die erneuerbare
Energie ganz hinzu letzte Frage an Sie
gibt es denn auch eine wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung die ihnen Hoffnung macht wo
es richtig gut läuft in Deutschland nun
was wirklich ein großer Pluspunkt ist es
wenn man in einer Krise diese nutzt um
sich neu aufzustellen das haben wir
jetzt bei den beschleunigten Verfahren
bei den lng-terminals so erlebt und das
sollten wir jetzt dringend auch nutzen
um die Verfahren in der Verwaltung
insgesamt zu beschleunigen aber auch die
Unternehmen sollten die Chance nutzen
mehr zu digitalisieren mir zu
automatisieren das brauchen sie auch um
mit dem Fachkräftemangel Problem
umzugehen denn sie werden in Zukunft
nicht mehr so viele Fachkräfte zur
Verfügung haben da ist jetzt die Stunde
um sich zu überlegen wie kann man die
Prozesse neu aufsetzen wie kann man an
der Stelle die richtigen Entscheidungen
die richtigen Weichen stellen um besser
für die Zukunft aufgestellt zu sein dann
hoffen wir dass die Regierung uns heute
Abend zugeschaut hat und sagen vielen
Dank an Monika Schnitzer sie ist die
Vorsitzende des der Wirtschaftsweisen
vielen Dank und einen schönen Abend nach
München einen schönen Abend
und das Gespräch haben wir um kurz vor
neuen aufgezeichnet hier geht es weiter
mit den Nachrichten und Hanna Zimmermann
und die beginnen mit einem Zwischenfall
an der polnisch-spiele russischen Grenze
ganz genau so ist es Polen hat
angekündigt seine Truppen an der Grenze
zu Belarus aufzustocken Grund sind zwei
belarussische Kampfhubschrauber die in
den polnischen Luftraum eingedrungen
sein sollen das Verteidigungsministerium
in Warschau sprach von einer Provokation
die nicht toleriert werden die
Nato-Partner seien informiert Fotos
zeigen die Hubschrauber die so tief
flogen dass sie vom Radarsystem nur
schwer erfasst werden konnten Belarus
bestreitet die Vorwürfe
russland hat erneut die Hafen
Infrastruktur der Ukraine angegriffen in
der Nacht wurde unter anderem der
Donauhafen in Ismail direkt an der
Grenze zu Rumänien getroffen laut hier
wurden insgesamt 40.000 Tonnen Getreide
vernichtet wir für afrikanische Länder
China und Israel bestimmt waren der
rumänische Staatspräsident Johannes
bezeichnete die Angriffe als
Kriegsverbrechen Zerstörung auch in Kiel
vier konnten zwar laut Ukraine alle zehn
Drohnen abgeschossen werden Trümmerteile
trafen allerdings Gebäude
nach dem Militärputsch im Niger sind
laut dem Auswärtigen Amt mehr als 40
deutsche aus dem westafrikanischen Land
ausgeflogen worden in der Nacht hatten
Frankreich und Italien damit begonnen
eigene und ausländische Staatsbürger in
Sicherheit zu bringen mittlerweile
verließen mehr als 800 Menschen den
Niger in evakuierungsflügen die im
landstationierten Bundeswehrsoldaten
sollen vorerst bleiben
die Jugendämter in Deutschland haben im
vergangenen Jahr so viele
Kindeswohlgefährdungen festgestellt wie
nie zuvor fast
62.300 Kinder und Jugendliche waren
psychischer körperlicher oder sexueller
Gewalt ausgesetzt oder wurden
vernachlässigt das erklärte das
Statistische Bundesamt damit stieg die
Zahl der Fälle im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
um 2300 die meisten Betroffenen waren
jünger als 14 Jahre
in der Gedenkstätte Auschwitz Birkenau
wurde heute an die Ermordung von etwa
500.000 sind die und Roma durch die
Nationalsozialisten im Zweiten Weltkrieg
erinnert in dem damaligen deutschen
Konzentrationslager wurden allein in der
Nacht auf den dritten august 1944 mehr
als 4000 sind die und Roma umgebracht
der Vorsitzende des Zentralrats der
Sinti und Roma in Deutschland Rose
mahnte es müsste der Anspruch der EU
sein Antiziganismus genauso zu echten
wie Antisemitismus
jemand der sich selbst über die
Verfassung stellt sollte niemals
Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten sein
das hat heute Mike Penz Republikaner und
US-Vizepräsident unter Donald Trump über
Donald Trump gesagt Pens will inzwischen
selbstkandidat für die
Präsidentschaftswahlen werden die dritte
Anklage gegen Trump ist mehr als nur ein
weiterer Prozess gegen einen
irrlichternden Ex-Präsidenten es geht um
das vielleicht wichtigste Prozedere in
einer Demokratie die Machtübergabe der
Vorwurf Trump habe nach seiner Abwahl
eine Verschwörung angezettelt mit dem
Ziel unrechtmäßig im Amt zu bleiben
quasi ein Putsch gegen den Wähler will
seiner neuerlichen Kandidatur wird auch
dieser Prozess vermutlich nicht schaden
den USA vielleicht schon Elma wissen
[Musik]
man
kann kommen heißt es in seinem Wahlkampf
Auftritt Song
oder man wird eben Präsident alles ist
möglich bei Trump bei Jack Smith nun
grünes Licht von den Geschworenen
bekommen hat der Sonderermittler soll
ihn zur Rechenschaft ziehen denn Trump
so steht es in der Anklageschrift habe
eine Verschwörung an geführt um die
Vereinigten Staaten zu betrügen Wähler
zu entmündigen und ein offizielles
Verfahren zu behindern
der Angriff auf das Kapitol am 6 Januar
2021 war nie gekannter Angriff auf den
Sitz der amerikanischen Demokratie war
befeuer durch Lügen Lügen des
Angeklagten mit der Absicht einer
Kernaufgabe des us-systems zu Schaden
beim Sturm aufs Kapitol hatten Trump
Anhänger versucht die parlamentarische
Bestätigung der Wahl Joe Biden zum
Präsidenten zu stoppen aufgestachelt von
Donald Trump persönlich
wir ziehen zum Capitol mit Schwäche
können wir unser Land nicht
zurückerobern ihr müsst Stärke zeigen
stark sein
es war ein Angriff auf das Herz der
amerikanischen Demokratie deshalb ist
die Anklage so brisant
in solchen Momenten sehen wir dass unser
Justizsystem funktioniert aber wir sehen
auch wie Navi einem Umsturz und einer
faschistischen Diktatur gekommen sind
es ist das wohl wichtigste von vier
großen Verfahren gegen Donald Trump im
März hatte ihn der Staatsanwalt von New
York wegen Steuerhinterziehung angeklagt
Trump soll schweige Geld Zahlungen an
die frühere Pornodarstellerin stormy
Daniels verschleiert haben dann die
zweite Anklage bei Trump rechtswidrig
geheime staatsdokumente auf seinem
Anwesen in Florida versteckt hatte die
Papiere darunter auch nuklear
Geheimnisse ließ der abgewählte
Ex-Präsident ungesichert Lagern einen
Teil sogar in einem Badezimmer und in
einem Veranstaltungssaal
und dann kommt bald wohl auch die
Anklage von der Staatsanwältin in
Georgia es geht auch um Wahlbetrug und
Erpressung unter anderem weil Trump per
Telefon den Innenminister Georgia's
unter Druck setzte
ich will doch nur
11.780 Stimmen finden so Trump beim
Versuch der Wahl Beeinflussung aus dem
Weißen Haus der Vorfall ist auch Teil
der Anklage in Washington Trump
bezeichnet das Verfahren nun als
illegalen Eingriff in den
wahlkampfvergleich des mit Methoden des
Nazi-Regimes nur wenige Republikaner
widersprechen
hier geht es nur darum dass Donald Trump
die Wahl verlor dann alles mögliche in
seiner Macht versuchte die Wahl zu
stehlen dabei scheiterte und nun zur
Wiederwahl antritt um dem Gefängnis zu
entgehen
ja Trump könnte ins Gefängnis kommen
aber rechtlich könnte er sogar dann noch
Präsident werden und sich selbst
begnadigen
dieser deutsche regensommer ist ein ganz
normaler mitteleuropäischer Sommer kühl
nass wechselhaft sagt unsere Kollegin
aus der Wetterredaktion und trotzdem
reicht der gefühlte Dauerregen dieser
Tage noch lange nicht aus um die
Trockenheit in tieferen Bodenschichten
zu bekämpfen
Dürre als Folge des Klimawandels ist ein
weltweites Phänomen mit dem wir uns in
den nächsten Wochen immer wieder mal
beschäftigen wollen unsere
Korrespondenten sind ausgewärmt um sich
die Folgen von Dürre und Maßnahmen
dagegen anzuschauen manchmal so wie in
den peruanischen Anden stoßen die
Menschen bei der Suche nach Wasser auf
uralte Lösungen ihrer
Vorfahren Christoph rückerath berichtet
aus Peru
die Hauptstadt von Peru liegt direkt am
Meer und mitten in der Wüste
Lima ist eine der trockensten Metropolen
der Welt in der rund 10 Millionen
Menschen leben für die das Wasser nicht
reicht die Flüsse die die Stadt
versorgen können den Bedarf nicht mehr
decken der Präsident der Wasserwerke der
Stadt zeigt sich hilflos
Lima ist die am schnellsten wachsende
Stadt in Lateinamerika und es regnet
hier nur ca 10 mm pro Jahr so viel wie
ein Eimer pro Quadratmeter
mögliche Abhilfe kommt von weit oben und
aus ferner Vergangenheit wir fahren raus
aus Lima von Null auf 4000 Meter Höhe in
die an hier entdecken die Nachfahren der
Inka eine mehr als 1000 Jahre alte
Technik wieder was aussieht wie ein
Trampelpfad ist eine amuna ein antiker
Bewässerungskanal aus vor kolonialer
Zeit diese Kanäle bauen sie jetzt wieder
auf
Saddam Techniker einer Stiftung die das
Projekt unterstützt will uns zeigen wie
doch bevor wir anfangen können müssen
wir den alten Göttern Respekt sollen wie
es hier Tradition ist
Clemente der Dorfälteste spricht das
Gebiet die koka-blätter die wir dabei
auch verzehren berauschen nicht helfen
aber gegen die Höhenkrankheit
dann geht es an die Arbeit die Kanäle
sind im Laufe der Jahrhunderte
zugewachsen müssen von Schlamm und
Geröll befreit die Mauern wieder
aufgebaut werden doch das lohnt sich
seit der Reaktivierung der amunas sehen
wir dass die Quellen wieder sprudeln und
wir wieder Wasser haben dass wir nutzen
können
etwa um die Felder zu bewässern oder
Trinkwasser zu gewinnen
die amunas säen Wasser sagen Sie hier
das Wasser fließt nicht auf direktem Weg
nach unten sondern entlang der Berge und
sättigt dabei die Böden nicht nur die
umliegenden Felder bekommen so wieder
Wasser der Grundwasserspiegel steigt
insgesamt und das hilft mittelfristig
auch unten in Lima
hier oben sind schon jetzt die Ernten
besser gelber Bautista und ihr Neffe
leben vom Ackerbau vor allem von jener
Pflanze die neben Coca die vielleicht
wichtigste ist hier in den Anden
Kartoffeln das ist die weiße Kartoffel
wir nennen sie hier junggeil
die sind sehr groß oder wie waren sie
früher bevor es die amunas gab früher
waren sie kleiner jetzt wo die amonas
Wasser bringen ist die Ernte viel besser
eine uralte Technik für die Probleme von
heute auf 4000 Metern wachsen die
Kartoffeln wieder und unten in Lima
hoffen sie aufsteigende Pegelstände
und mehr zum Thema können Sie heute
Nacht gegen 0 Uhr 15 sehen in der
Ausland schon mal Doku Kampf ums Wasser
vom Gletscher bis in die Wüste die ganze
Reihe schon ab sofort in der ZDF
Mediathek mit neuen Folgen den ganzen
August über
und bei uns geht es jetzt weiter mit
Hannah und den Nachrichten aus der
Wirtschaft und der überraschenden
Herabstufung einer Supermacht ja wir
blicken noch einmal Richtung USA die
Ratingagentur Fitch hat nämlich die
Kreditwürdigkeit der Vereinigten Staaten
um eine Stufe herabgesetzt das Land
verliert damit seine Bestnote Valerie
Haller womit begründet Fitch denn diese
Abstufung ja Fitch begründet das mit der
hohen Verschuldung der USA und verweist
auf die schlechte Haushaltslage zu dem
kritisiert Fisch die so wörtlich Erosion
der Regierungsführung ja und tatsächlich
war ja das wochenlange politische
Gezerre um die Schulden Obergrenze
dieses Mal besonders bedrohlich die
Einigung kam nur kurz vor knapp und ohne
hätte sein Zahlungsausfall gegeben mit
schwer absehbaren Folgen für die
Weltkonjunktur welche Konsequenzen hat
nun dieser Schritt vermutlich keine
gravierenden die USA sind die weltweit
größte Wirtschaftsmacht und müssen daher
nicht befürchten dass Anleger jetzt
scharenweise amerikan diese
Staatsanleihen aus dem Depot werfen aber
es ist schon ein Schuss vor den Bug denn
zwei von den drei großen
Rating-Agenturen haben den USA die
begehrte Spitzenbonität entzogen und
außerdem rechnet Fitch dieses Jahr mit
einer Rezession für die US-Wirtschaft
die USA sind wichtiger Absatzmarkt für
deutsche Konzerne das Minus entsprechend
deutlich die letzte Herabstufung der USA
liegt mehr als zehn Jahre zurück damals
verlor der DAX in wenigen Tagen 25
Prozent diesmal reagieren die
Aktienmärkte weit cooler vielen Dank
Valerie für diese Einordnung heute
heute am 2 august hat die Menschheit
rein rechnerisch bereits alle
natürlichen Ressourcen der Erde für
dieses Jahr verbraucht der sogenannte
erdüberlastungstag orientiert sich vor
allem am Ausstoß von CO2 ab sofort leben
wir quasi auf Pump und bräuchten bis zum
Jahresende für unseren Konsum 1,7 Erden
statt nur einer
1971 lag der Erd überlastungstag noch im
Dezember seitdem wandert er stetig in
Richtung Sommer
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Mittwoch
die lauten 7 21 23 29 30 44 Superzahl 4
alle Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr
eigentlich zählten die Brasilianerinnen
bei der Fußball-WM der Frauen zu den
Favoritinnen doch nun ist die Mannschaft
in der Vorrunde ausgeschieden nach einem
0:0 gegen Jamaika im Achtelfinale stehen
also die jamaikanerinnen genauso wie
Frankreich das sechs zu drei gegen
Panama siegte ebenfalls weiter Südafrika
das gegen Italien gewann und Schweden
das gegen Argentinien triumphierte und
morgen steht dann auch das letzte
Gruppenspiel der deutschen Mannschaft an
gegen Südkorea nur mit einem Sieg ist
nur mit einem Sieg ist die Nationalelf
sicher weiter
bloß nicht ins Stolpern kommen lautet
das Motto der DFB Frauen für das dritte
und entscheidende gruppenmatch droht bei
einer Pleite das früheste WM aus
klar weiß man dass es vielleicht auch
das letzte sein könnte aber dann wollen
wir uns gar nicht beschäftigen sondern
wir wollen morgen da rausgehen zeigen
was wir können unsere Qualität auf dem
Platz bringen um sein Team zu schlagen
der Engländer Collin Bell wurde einst
mit den Frankfurterinnen Champions
League Sieger vermittelt seit 2019 den
südkoreanerinnen seine Spielidee pressen
sehr selten aber vielleicht überraschen
Sie uns ja morgen also Colin Bell ist ja
ein Trainerfuchs und doch geht das Team
von Voss Tecklenburg als klarer Favorit
in die Begegnung auch weil mit Marina
Hegering nach überstandener
Fersenverletzung erstmals die
Abwehrchefin auflaufen wird genau
rechtzeitig um die Hürde fürs
Achtelfinale zu nehmen
Spiel der deutschen Frauen gibt es dann
morgen live hier im ZDF zu sehen ist um
12 Uhr und wir empfehlen Ihnen jetzt
sehr das Ausland schon mal direkt im
Anschluss und gegen 0 Uhr dann das heute
journal Update mit dem letzten Stand der
Dinge einen schönen Abend ihn tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend in den vergangenen 7 Tagen
hat es in Deutschland zum Teil sehr
kräftig geregnet spitzenreiter ist der
hohe rotskopf im Vogelsberg mit 137
Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter innerhalb
von 7 Tagen die obersten 10 bis 40
Zentimeter des Oberbodens sind also zur
Zeit in Deutschland gut durchfeuchtet
und auch heute Nacht regnet es noch
kräftig weiter Regenschauer und Gewitter
ziehen weiter Richtung Nordosten und
dazu pfeift der Wind stürmisch die
Temperaturen sinken heute Nacht auf 17
bis 12 Grad und morgen erwarten uns in
den westlichen Mittelgebirgen um die 17
Grad im Osten wird es mit 24 Grad wärmer
und auch morgen beschäftigt uns noch das
Sturmtief Xan es liegt dann über der
Nordseeküste und des drohen weitere
schwere Sturmböen in den Mittelgebirgen
das wird morgen ein garstiger Tag in
Norddeutschland mit kräftigen
Regenfällen die zum Teil mit Gewittern
durchsetzt sind freundche ist es im
südlichen Brandenburg und in Sachsen
sowie vom Vogtland bis zum Bodensee auch
im Berchtesgadener Land jetzt noch
einzelne Regenschauer und sehr
wechselhaft geht es in den nächsten
Tagen weiter bei Höchsttemperaturen von
14 bis 24 Grad und wenn Sie sich fragen
wann dieses wechselhafte Wetter denn
doch mal endet hier am Trend für
Oberstdorf sehen sie so ab Montag
nächster Woche geht es doch aufwärts in
Sachen Temperaturen und in Sachen
Sonnenschein guten Abend